when you first start flying you're gonna
you get sick when we were filming I kind
of my deal was when I made my deal I
said I've got to fly in the F-14 so I
had to go through all the ejector seat
training and first pilot that I flew
with his name was Bozo so we're going
out and we're just right a couple feet
off the deck in the desert and we're
just sweating I'm sweating in the F-14
uh because we were doing heavy Maneuvers
if I leaned down like this and he at
that point decided to pull up
pulled up so hard and for so long I mean
I can't do it now my head literally was
touching the ground the g-force had
expressed my spine and the push to talks
right here I was going like this
it's like you know I mean he was going
up forever so finally he leveled off and
I just I had the bag of my head I was
like I suppose so
what's didn't you see I like you get a
check you didn't tell me you were gonna
do that my head was like what he says
yeah yeah they don't call me Bozo for
nothing